là où ça bouge ce soir on va parler de
spectacle pour enfant qui s'appelle
petit navire mais avant d'aller sur les
flots et de parler de bâton on retrouve
tout de suite mathieu qui se trouve à
argentan pour une exposition vcro là où
ça bouge se déplacent argentan pour une
exposition qui s'appelle parcours
parallèles entre peinture et vitrail
nous allons voir tout de suite à quoi ça
ressemble bonjour bonjour se feront
chambre et c'est merci de nous recevoir
dans votre exposition ces gentilles
venir d'abord ça c'est parmi les
dernières heures c'est ça c'est sûr ça
fait partie des dernières oeuvres
alors c'est vraiment sur le thème nature
il ya beaucoup de le feuillage de thèmes
naturel qui reviennent dans votre oeuvre
on peut dire il ya beaucoup de choses et
puis en même les événements parce que
j'ai travaillé toutes ces pièces sont
sur le parti sur le problème du
réchauffement climatique
florent chaboissier maîtres verriers
mais c'est avant tout un explorateur de
formes et de couleurs
un artisan d'art qui a trouvé dans le
vert son terrain d'expression favori
mon travail c'est tout ce qui laisse
passer la lumière m'intéresse et donc je
me suis toujours posé la question de
savoir comment première rom en levant la
une feuille quelque chose vers le soleil
a trouvé ça fantastique
je suis dans la création et je suis
aussi je me pousse à montrer des choses
justement votre atelier on peut visiter
il est en normandie on va on va les voir
avec vous voir un peu comment vous
travaillez avec plaisir bien sûr
il ya deux choses
il ya là une couleur à part un bond de
bord tout est cuit parce que quand elles
sont faites donc là vous avez sur une
surface là j'ai travaillé avec des avec
une sanguine
enfin une teinte sanguine et puis sur
l'autre côté je travaille avec des
jaunes d'argent qui sont des chlorures
d'argent qui eux par cémentation on dit
pénètre dans le vert et c'est parti pour
quelques milliers d'années
quelques milliers d'années parce que
c'est en fait le support qui dure le
plus longtemps finalement oui c'est par
exemple les vitraux qu'on a du train et
du 12e ou du troisième ont plus été
abîmée avec l'arrivée du mazout et du
chauffage au mazout dans les villes en
50 ans tous et esquinté alors que ça
avait tenu pendant huit siècles la
lumière en fait nous n'habitons pas les
vitraux non non non au contraire la
sublime son rôle cette sublime et les
vitraux
pour moi le vitrail comme tout c'est un
moyen d'expression
c'est pour ça que je parle de la
peinture de la sculpture métal verre
papier majeur je me sers de matériaux de
technique mais je suis pas au service
d'une technique je suis pas maître
verrier traditionnelle qui passe son
temps va instaurer des vitraux art fair
des losanges dans des églises ou des
choses comme ça les vitraux mais aussi
les peintures de florent chaboissier
sont visibles à la médiathèque
d'argentan
jusqu'au 21 mai
là où ça bouge à la fermeture éclair
pour vous parler d'un spectacle pour
enfant qui s'appelle le petit navire il
était un peu c'est ça c'est ça
c'est à partir de la comptine pour
enfant on a inventé un spectacle
davanture joué par trois musiciens
comédiens qui font tous qui font les
bruitages sur scène qui joue tous les
personnages
enfin c'est un vrai ballet sim histoire
de pirates on croise quelques pirates
ouais trop bien ça se joue quand ça se
joue les deux prochains week-ends à 16
heures samedi et dimanche
alors n'ayez pas peur hein vous bravez
les travaux vous venez ici à l'abord du
tatami
voilà et vous pouvez aussi si ces
nouveautés retrouver ce récit faux
livres voilà un roman illustré par
marine duché un roman de nicholas ray le
petit navire à partir de 6 ans à la
fermeture éclair
bizarre on dirait qu'il ya de l'orage
si tu
et puis demain nous serons ici à la
brèche à cherbourg en cotentin pour vous
parlé d'une grande artiste elle
s'appelle phia ménard et le festival
spring du concept août une rétrospective
on a rendez vous avec elle à demain